hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round six of
the 2021 norway chess it's magnus
carlson versus alireza ferruja and it's
a game where
nothing is really happening but that's
only because we don't know what's
happening so yeah it's a really really
complicated game but uh it seems like
it's a simple one but here you will just
realize how much we really know about
chess so without further ado let's check
it out magnus with the white pieces
opens with e4 we have e5 from ferruja
knight f3 knights to c6 and bishop to b5
he goes for the royal opus
and now not the berlin defense firuja
will try something more more um well i i
don't want to say creative but something
less uh
um
drawish uh so a6 uh morphe's defense we
have bishop to a4 and now knight to f6
we have castles and b5 so just uh very
very natural stuff so bishop back to b3
bishop to c5 now and a4 attacking the at
the advanced pawn chain on the queen
side we have rook to b8 and now c3 we
have d6 by black and now d4 striking in
the center bishop to b6 in the now a5 so
this is a position we've had many times
on this channel and we uh always uh
mention why it's uh bad to capture
either with the bishop or the knight but
just in case you're new to chess or the
channel i will briefly show it so now
you don't want to capture with the
bishop because then we have this very
nice idea of d captures on e5 the
captures we trade queens captures
captures and now we play bishop to d5
and you're either losing the knight or
the bishop
so nothing fun is really happening here
even if you capture the bishop just pawn
captures you have to lose the knight or
the bishop
and on the other hand if you capture
with the knight then we capture it with
the rook rook captures bishop captures
and now we have this very nice attack
against uh just the entire black's
position uh d captures an e5d captures
we trade queens queen captures with
czech king captures now knight captures
an e5 and now black will either suffer
knight captures on f7 with the check or
knight to c6 with check so you're gonna
win back material and retain a better
position so after a5 we have bishop back
to a7 by ferruja and now h3 so this is
all been played before nothing new here
bishop to be seven nothing with the uh
really awesome bishop player and the
bishop to e3 by magnus so sacrificing
the e4 pawn uh knight captures on e4 and
now there are some uh top tier games
where this position has been reached
rook to e1 is a known move also d5 is a
known move uh just exposing this knight
to the attack also the bishop becomes
vulnerable but here magnus just plays
knight b to d2 and it is now as of move
13 that we have a completely new game uh
so let's see how ferugia deals with this
uh he captures the knight knight
captures on d2 we have queen captures on
d2 and now he just castles and now
magnus says all right this isn't uh
maybe the most ambitious way to tackle
this position so i'm just going to win
back my pawn uh d captures an e5 d
captures we have queen captures on d8
rook b captures on d8 and now bishop
captures an a7 uh knight captures an a7
and knight captures on e5 and after all
this capture fest is finished we have
this position where the material is
completely equal three points each on
the king side three pawns each on the
queen side both players have a light
square bishop uh a knight and two rooks
so of course uh black is controlling the
open d d file it's natural that white
will also place a rook on on the d file
so first we have bishop to d5 black
wants to trade off um uh the light
square bishops and now bishop to c to
magnus so it wants to keep the bishops
on the board knight to c6 now and uh the
knights get traded off knight captures
bishop captures and now rook a to d1 so
grabbing the open d file uh furuja puts
the other rook on the open f file and
now magnus trades with rook capture 78
we have rook capture 78 and now we have
this completely uninteresting position
or seemingly uninteresting where both
players have equal material both players
have a light score bishop a rook and a
king
and now even rook to d1
magnus offers now a queen a rook trade
we have rook captures in bishop capture
so now even further simplifying the
position so what can be done here well
let's uh put in a few moves and see what
happens king to f8 we have f4 by magnus
very nice as it puts upon on the dark
square he has a light square bishop so
uh naturally both players have a light
square bishop you want your own pawns to
be on dark squares and you want your
opponent's pawns to be on light square
so your pawns will not be targets for
your opponent's bishop whereas his pawns
will be targets for your own bishop so
sort of a long term idea uh king to e7
we have king to f2 king to d6 in the now
b4 not allowing king to c5 and now
grabbing more space here as you can see
magnus placed all of his pawns on dark
squares and he has a light square bishop
so he has that going for him and you
can't really be too active with the king
here if king to d5 we're just going to
play bishop to e2 and now you can't
further grab a space here for example
with king to e4 because bishop f3 just
wins the bishop so there's no way for
the king to get
too active
so after b4 we have bishop to d5 by
ferugia now g4 by magnus we have h6 and
now even g5 so putting uh all of uh all
of his pawns on dark squares uh h
captures f captures and now c5 rujo
wants to trade off a few pawns simplify
the position even further king to e3
magnus improves the position of his king
now c captures on b4 c captures on b4
and now king to e5 grabbing opposition
and magnus just plays h4 so now this is
the position four pawns each a bishop
each or king each but magnus has all of
his pawns on dark squares whereas first
pawns are mostly on light squares so the
light square bishop is pretty much
useless here you can never attack the
pawns on the dark squares and magnus
will he can but it's not going to be
easy if this bishop could somehow come
to b7 and grab hold of those pawns so
get in the back of the pawn chain that'd
be great but that's not gonna happen so
g6 uh and what can you do now we have
bishop to g4 by magnus we have bishop to
e6 offering a trade of bishops and here
if you trade it's uh much better for
black because now black gets a
past pawn and it's going to be really
hard to defend this for example king f3
king f5 now if you move the king we go
after these pawns if you keep the king
somewhere here king to g3 we will
continue pushing our e pawn and at some
point you're gonna sacrifice this pawn
to grab hold of these pawns and then you
will have a winning end game so instead
after bishop to e6 magnus goes for a
little trick here he plays h5 now saying
okay if you capture my bishop i'm i'm
playing h6 and you can't stop my pawn
it's going to queen so after h5 perugia
has to play g captures on h5 we have
bishop captures and now king to f5 so
magnus will lose this pawn
but on the other hand he grabs hold of
this diagonal bishop to f3 now if firuja
goes after the pawn right away then
bishop here and that's just the game so
after bishop to f3 we have bishop to c8
furuja not allowing this says i'm going
to capture this pawn later on and now
king the d4 magnus sacrifices this pawn
to gain some activity with his king so
king king captures on g5 and now
if you go king to c5 which is uh i know
something that you guys want to do then
black pushes f5 king to b6 f4 and black
spawn is simply too far advanced for a
maneuver like bishop to f7 a bishop to
b7 we can trade and then just continue
pushing our past pawn so white would not
be in time here
uh to win the game it would of course be
sufficient for a draw so after king
captures on g5 magnus goes back king to
e5 now asking felucia what do you play
here and it's a really really
complicated position uh problem is if
you play something like f6 with check
and i know this is again something that
we all would do then you get king to d6
and then after f5 it seems like it's the
same but now you gain another tempo king
the c7 attacking the bishop and after
the bishop moves now bishop to b7 and
now this bishop uh came here much much
faster than in the other line that we
discussed so after king to king t5
firuja pushes f5 right away he wants to
get this f4 move in so king to d6 and
now f4 you could also consider king to
f4 as the
bishop will have to move so you know
it's uh maybe a good idea but okay we
have f4 and now king back to e5 not king
to c7 king to e5 and this is a really
brilliant move by magnus because now
these squares are taken away from the
black king and if you move the bishop
then you allow magnus bishop to b7 if
you move the king then you allow simply
king captures on f4 and here there's
really nothing better alireza has to
step back and allow magnus to capture
this pawn so you can as you can see he
grabbed some space allowed furuja to
grab this pawn here and then he comes
back forces black to waste to move as
there's nothing better and then he's
gonna reclaim his pawn while keeping a
better position of his king so that's
some a very very nice prophylactic
king movement there
we have king the g6 king captures on f4
and now bishop to f6 and now you have
this position where it seems like
everything is you know just the same
completely equal but it's not magnus is
completely winning here so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
amazing move while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible idea that and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop to b7 that of course is not true
i'm only checking if you guys are paying
attention the move is bishop to d5 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this and now you can see that we've
taken away the e5 and the e6 squares
away from the black king and well that's
uh that's a huge deal uh the black king
cannot go anywhere here and if you move
the bishop from the defense of b7 then
bishop b7 wins we're just gonna gobble
up these pawns uh so you have to play
a move with the king or you don't uh
we're gonna show what happens if you
just move the king then you allow king
to e5 this is a really important square
uh king to d7 we're going to play bishop
to e6 check and now let's say after king
to c7 we can just trade here captures
captures king d6 and the black king will
not be able to defend his pawns we're
just going to grab the opposition here
king a7 grab the opposition again and
after the king moves king b6 and now all
of these pawns will fall and we win the
end game very easily so instead after
bishop to d5 alireza said all right i
know this will not work and i have to
try with bishop to d7 even though it
will cost me the a6 pawn
but it's uh you know it's a better try
than king to e7 so bishop to b7 and now
king to e6 and now i know you guys
really want to grab the pawn but that's
not the way to go if we grab the pawn
then you allow bishop to c6 and now
after you try getting the king into the
game because now black is the one
controlling these squares with the king
and bishop king e3 king d5 and how are
you getting in with the king king the
three king e five all of these squares
are covered there's no way for the white
king to get anywhere here and the bishop
covers a8 so you don't really care about
the past a pawn
so after king to e6 magnus again plays
the uh absolute best king to e4 there's
always time to capture the pawn on a6
king to d6 and now only now bishop
captures an a6 we have bishop to c6
check king to d4 now it's black who has
to move the king so here or you don't
rather if king the c7 we just play king
to c5 and it's uh win we're going to
capture the b5 phone that's game so of
course alireza has has to once again
play with the bishop bishop to e8 but
now bishop to b7 controlling a6 and a8
so what can you play here bishop to d7
and now the problem is if magnus hurries
up with a6 then bishop to c6 and it's a
draw you can't push the pawn because
bishop captures on b7 and if you trade
here of course you are nowhere near in
time to do anything about this if a7
king b7 and it's a draw so after bishop
to b7 we have bishop back to f3 and now
it's a bit different now if you play
bishop to c6 nothing is really happening
because you can just trade here and your
pawn is safe on a5 you can gain uh king
to e5 king to c7 and now king to d5 if
king to b7 we simply play king to c5 and
of course uh sorry king to c5 and now if
this we just gained the opposition and
then pick up this pawn that's all there
is to it
uh so after bishop to f3 bishop the c8
by ferugia guarding against a6 but now
bishop to e2 going after the b5 pawn
bishop to d7 defending and now bishop to
d3 so now we're coming here once the
dark square but once the dark light
square bishop moves bishop to c6 and
here magnus played bishop to e4 and it
was in this position on move 52 that
alireza furuja resigned to the game and
the magnus achieved his first victory in
the classical time format so here you
resign because if you trade then of
course it's a very easy win two points
against one and uh well you will not be
able to keep an eye on the on the b5
pawn white will easily win it and then
win the game and if you don't capture it
if you just move the bishop bishop
anywhere if you go anywhere along this
diagonal of course we'll we're just
going to capture it so if you move it uh
just a6 there's no way to defend king to
c7 now a7 and now the b8 and b7 squares
are guarded by the pawn and the bishop
the black king cannot approach this and
of course we win the game if you block
we simply capture king captures we bring
a queen into the game it's game over so
like i said an extremely
uh
seemingly simple game that turned
complicated uh you know
uh just because it's uh it's an endgame
so that's why you guys should always
study the end game as in the end game
there are so many of these hidden
resources that you can use you know to
somehow overcome your opponent uh when
there's seemingly nothing there to be
done
once again magnus squeezes water from
stone successfully and this time it was
uh there is a ferruja on the receiving
end so first win for magnus and
classical uh we'll see what this means
for the standings after we check out at
least another game from round six of the
norway chess 2021 uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it i feel
most certainly did not uh i would like
to thank the beef aisle tom derala happy
birthday header rose uh tom kitching and
stephen shinley for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day